hello everyone the moment you've all
been waiting for is finally here this is
game six from the 1960 World Chess
Championship match McHale towel versus
Mikhail Botvinnik and for those of you
who are only seeing this game for the
first time I envy all because this is
one of the greatest and most complicated
games you'll ever see especially since
it was played in the World Chess
Championship match now I will try to
cover some of the most important parts
of this game but to really grasp grasp
with the full complexity of this game
you should really acquire towels book he
wrote about this game so without further
ado let's check it out so it's a game 6
tall one game number one and then four
games were drawn although they were
extremely complex and fierceful but this
is game six and Botvinnik
again opens with c4 and this is his
favorite continue I mean continuation
his favorite opening move as unlike for
d4 he doesn't he doesn't show what his
plans in the game are so black can't
immediately go for some well analyzed
defense but we can pretty much transpose
into anything from c4 so talo comes with
Knight to f6 and we have Knight to f3
and although Knight to f3 can still
transpose into anything we're still in
the English opening but it gives Stahl
two very important things to consider
for one botanique does not intend to
play the nimzo-indian and number two if
tall ever goes for the Kings Indian
defense botanique is not gonna go for
the sharp same variation as there is
already a knight on f3
so what eunuch will be unable to play
pawn to f3 so with these two things in
mind at all continues with g6 and he
says an opening like this wouldn't would
never be played by someone like Cheverny
for example in the 1930s as black
doesn't really engage in any of the
central squares in the beginning of the
game but still explains that later
players like boleslav scheme bronstein
Gaylor really gave new life to Kings
Indian defense so g3 Bishop to g7 and
now Bishop to g2 now castles we have d4
and now d6 so we've transposed into the
Kings Indian defense Knight to c3 by
botanique and here tal says that in a
lot of his games he played a more like
c5 and then depending on whether white
will push d5 or not maybe he will
develop the knight to c6 or d7 but he
said he says as he played this in a lot
of in a lot of his other games he
decided to go for Knight B to d7
immediately and it chances are about
tuning didn't really have a chance to
prepare for a move like this LS tal
didn't play it too that often and with
this he gives himself a lot of options
here about 20 castles and top lazy 5 we
have E 4 and now c6 and now tal
considers this to be the most flexible
variation for black as now if white ever
decides to push d5 then tile can go a5
and create a very nice outpost for his
knight and c5 so nothing to worry about
here and here botanique played H 3 and H
3 isn't considered to be such a great
move but what week already played in his
game 14 against miss lock in their World
Championship match in this position he
continued with Bishop to e3
but after dismissal attacted with 94
Bishop to g5 Smithville played Queen to
b6 and here he gained a lot of
initiative so instead a botany goes for
h3 doesn't allow this knight to come to
g4 and tile goes for Queen to b6 Queen
to b6 also isn't such a move that was
often seen more was seen something like
capturing on e4 and after Knight
captures rook to e8
so again tau goes for a move that
Botvinnik probably didn't prepare for so
much Queen to b6 and here Botnick played
d5 if Botvinnik
didn't do this if he went for example a
move like king to h2 simply improving
the position of the king then tal has
this very old tactic in mind each
captors on d4 and after Knight captures
Queen captures and now after Queen
captures Knight to g4 check opening up a
discovered attack on the Queen pawn
captures Bishop captures and now the
material is equal
but White's pawn structure is somewhat
shattered and the black would definitely
have an advantage in this game so after
Queen b6
Botvinnik plays d5 and here we have a C
captor Sundy 5c captor son d5 and
mountain Knights the c5 and here tal was
extremely pleased with the opening phase
of the game he managed to complete his
task he activated his night a night on a
very active post on c5 the queen and b6
is preventing white from dislodging it
with before although it's unclear if
white would immediately push before but
you know it's a it's a nice definitely a
nice outpost for the night and here
usually here but when he played Knights
the e1 and the toast I thought that this
Knights the e1 move was a novelty by
botanique later after this game he found
out that
Petrosyan already played this move in
one of his games and he won the game
pretty swiftly with the white pieces so
but when he was familiar with this game
but knife to e1 didn't really like this
move as petrosian's opponent didn't
really play correctly that game so a
more usual idea is a rook to e1 guarding
d4 pawn and then playing Knight to see -
and bring the Knight to c4 as the this
is a very active square for the white
knight but okay Knight the e1 by
botanique and now comes Bishop to d7
we have Knight to b3 and this is
something tal says that that Botvinnik
is a great player and he's a great
player in chess matches but this is
white tile considers it's very important
to play tournaments especially open
tournaments where you will face a lot of
players with different styles here it
took between 10 minutes to consider a
move Knight to d3 and the only reason a
reason white would play in night Stewie
one and the previous move is to bring it
to d3 and exchange it for four tiles a
very strong night on c5 but here tal
says because it took between in 10
minutes to play this move it really
shows that botanique lacks simply
playing games as this move should have
been an automatic and those 10 minutes
will really be
missed by Botanica later in the game so
night capture Sunday 3 Queen captures on
d3 and here rook F to c8 by tal and
Brooke we have to see it tells us that
he really took a long time to find this
move because it's unclear what to do
here and we want to bring the play over
to the Queen side or do you want to play
a move like night to H sorry nice to h5
and start pushing the pawns the problem
is if you go night to h5 immediately
after Bishop to e3 Queen captures on b2
or Queen to d8 simply rook to be won and
you you're gonna lose the b7 point so
after this Bishop to e3
you should retreat with the Queen to d8
but then Queen to e2 and again this
Queen to d2 stops f5 pretty nicely as
after f5 after you push it simply
captures you can't capture with the pawn
because the knight is hanging on h5 and
after rook captures Queen to c4 and the
whites position is great here you can
never play rock to see 8 for example
winter before is coming and now you're a
7b7 and d6 pawns are under attack
so it took down a long time it doesn't
say how much but it took him a long time
and he played rook F to c8 he decided
that he wants the trans transpose the
game over to the Queen side at some
point play rook to c4 double up rooks
and the C file and he thinks that later
in the game night h5 can be followed by
f5 without the rockin f8 supporting it
so rook to be 1 and tau thought that
this rook to be one move isn't really
something okay it gets the rook out of
the a one diagonal a one g7 out of this
bishops reach in the future and also it
will protect the b2 point so this Bishop
can become activated but it actually is
a loss of a tempo and that will prove
this later in the game
Queen to e2 would have been better than
rook to b1 s going to e 2 also guards at
the B to pawn and will attack the knight
on h5 after tal finally transfers it
there so nice to h5 and here Bishop to
e3
and now tal says that he didn't want to
bring the Queen back to d8 as he already
brought his rook over to the Queen side
so Tom wants to play
on the queenside something not very
characteristic of a Kings Indian defense
but he thinks that he will be able to
perform at five without the help of the
rock on f8 so instead here top plays
Queen to b4 now both unique plays who
into e2 as that threat of f5 is pretty
dangerous if black is ever allowed to
play G captures on f5 then he will
create a very nice pawn storm and here
rook to c4 again it took quite some time
to this to decide on this move he
considered f5 immediately but as you'll
see if thought Wade had 5 immediately
then after he captures Bishop captures
rook b2 c1 getting rock out of the way
tal kind of gives up his grab grasp of
the e4 square so he didn't really enjoy
this as he doesn't really have anything
to do here and the White has this threat
of playing g4
so after this Queen to e to move tile
improves with rook to c4 and now gaining
even more pressure on d4 square and
preparing rook a to c8 here rook F to c1
by botanique and here it took tile again
some 16 minutes as he says they decide
to double up rooks and the Kings and the
Queen side as again he had to see if
everything was in order on the Kings
side and here both eunuch thought that
there was really no danger here in this
position he thought that everything was
fine he played King 2h to simply
improving the position of the King later
he will decide to go Bishop to f1 and
try to gain some exchanges here on the
Queen side and he thought this was this
was okay because the bishop and g7 and
the knight and h5 are on the King side
so if he manages to exchange everything
on the Queen side all will be well
but here comes something tal planned for
a very long time and that's why he took
so long to calculate all the moves that
if he's allowed to play on the Queen
side top plate f5 we have each captures
on f5 as planned Bishop captures on f5
now Bishop captures on f5 is a lot a lot
stronger than when this rook was an f1
because now this rock is under attack
Botvinnik is forced to lose the tempo
here so rook to a1
and this is the moment that both unique
and probably all the grandmasters that
were watching the game old audio of all
the people in the audience here
Botvinnik thought that since the bishop
is an f5 denied is an h5 there's this
threat of winning the peace with g4 so
tal would have no other option than to
retreat with his pieces but it's in this
game that table played one of the
greatest moves I've ever seen and in
this position
top played Knight to f4 so when you when
you see a move like Knight to f4 on game
6 and the towel is already in the lead
in this match he has the black pieces
and he plays a move like this you you
don't know what to make of it you're
Mikhail Botvinnik tell just you know
just through that night in on f4 what do
you do here well firstly your queen is
under attack I need to so what can you
do if you decide for some reason not to
capture the night if you play Bishop
captures then simply e captures on f4
Tull opens up this Bishop for free and
g7 you put g4 you attack at Bishop to e5
is coming with the threat of f3 winning
the Queen very unpleasant position for
black on the other hand after Knight to
f4 you could decide for example move
your queen but if you if you do this
then Thal eliminates this very powerful
defender of between X King Knight
capture screen captures and then h5
solidifying here again a very unpleasant
position for both for Botvinnik tal has
the bishop pair the rooks are nicely
doubled here both eunuchs rook anyone is
out of the game it would be a very nice
position for tall so after Knight to a4
Botvinnik did the only thing he could do
he captured the knight G captures on f4
and top lady captures on f4 so I mean
it's like nothing happened
he just activated his Bishop he
sacrificed the piece but again both
Winnick has to decide what to do here
and this position was thoroughly
analyzed after this game and days after
this game only days after this game was
played have improvements been found for
both eunuchs position so here both
eunuch saw that his bishop doesn't
really have a lot of squares if you play
Bishop characters and a7 then Queen a5
simply wins the bishop back as
the bishop has no retreat squares on the
other hand you don't really have a lot
have a lot of options here
later there was there were even articles
written written about this game that a
botany in this position should have
continued with a three and now after
Queen to b3 and now you could for
example capture on a seven but here tall
said that he would probably continue
with Bishop to e5 with the threat of f3
and after white pushes f3 he would now
play b6 and now although tile is down a
piece this Bishop is out of the game
Todd can always win it with a rope to c7
and the light square bishop is also out
of the game due to this silly f3 move so
even though white is better here tall
considers that under under time pressure
there is no way to play this position
with white and some other interesting
ideas were found after the game was
played for example after this Queen to
b3 move Queen to d1 was also an idea
found but I mean it's easy to find ideas
after the game is played so after it
captures on f4 but when he had to make a
decision and he played Bishop to d2 and
this Bishop to d2 simply gives a white
more than enough compensation so in that
position a3 was the only move here the
the point here is no longer defended
here top plays Queen captures on b2 it
took him some 15 minutes to consider
queen capture some unbe too and it's
exactly because of that that tal says
that the knight sacrifice on f4 was
purely intuitive he didn't have a
follow-up for example I'll play Knight
f4 and then when both meaning does this
I have a variation prepared no he
sacrificed it and then after he saw what
Botvinnik will do then he considered a
lot of things for example he he thought
about Bishop to e5 immediately without
capturing on b2 first and only after f3
to capture on b2 but then he saw that
after night to d1 attacking the Queen
and Queen to d4 rook captures and c4
rook captures on c4 rook to c1 rook
captures Bishop captures and after Queen
captures on d5 and Bishop to F
one table would have three points for
the piece but he thought that his three
extra points were not enough
compensation for both eunuchs extra
piece so instead after this Bishop to d2
by Botvinnik
he decided to play queen capture some b2
and now rook a to be 1 by Botvinnik
and it's very interesting now that you
capture immediately Knight to d1 simply
doesn't work because now Queen to e5
wins the game what do you do here if you
exchange Queens okay Bishop captures on
e5 and now your rook is attacked on a1
and also tell has a threat of f3 winning
the bishop and g2 so after Queen B 2
botany plays rook a2 b1 attacking the
Queen but also giving up the exchange
and here comes the move that pretty much
shattered all of botanics composure here
at all did consider capturing and b1 of
course you can do this but here tau
played another tall move he played f3
and in a position like this you were
already so so so shocked when top played
Knight to a4 now now you get this f3
move and again you have to make a
decision what do you do here do capture
do capture the pawn with the Bishop do
captured with the Queen you can't
capture with the Queen your Bishop on d2
is hanging do you capture blacks Queen
and B - what do you do here so towel
thought when he played this move he
didn't consider it too much because he
didn't want to waste too much time but
he saw that the immediate Bishop
captures on f3 would result in Bishop
capture some b1 and after rook captures
4 he would play Queen to c2 and here you
would have a repetition of moves
probably a drawing game would it
continue like this he doesn't know as he
didn't calculated enough during the game
but he said he says even if botanique
saw this variation he was under a lot of
pressure I mean he had the white pieces
he was already down a whole point in the
match and you don't want to allow some
23 year old guy from latvia to to force
a draw like this after all you are both
unique I mean you you crushed world
champions like since they existed
so here botanique played
rook captures Queen and b2 and this
actually is the losing move here top
plate pawn captures Queen and e2 and now
you can't really you can't really do
anything here you can't capture the pawn
the bishop will capture a rockin b2 so
rook to b3 was played here top played
rook to d4 there was there was even
another possibility here even greater
one but it all says that he saw that
Bishop to e5 was probably winning but at
this point in the game there was so much
noise from the audience in the crowd
that everyone was really upset about
this game how it was going about that
night sacrifice and everything you know
not just regular viewers grandmasters
also so the the arbiters had to
interfere and they had moved the game to
a backstage room where there was no
audience and tal says that this didn't
really he didn't really enjoy this as he
likes the crowd he likes denies of the
crowd so moving the game to a back room
where there wasn't any noise it was only
favoring Botvinnik and that was really
hoping for a win in this game but yeah
but by instead of destructor e4 rook to
e4 top could have played Bishop T if
I've checked and this is winning on the
spot now after you block this simply
rook captures on c3 rook captures and
now rock captors on c3 and there is no
way to capture the rook and c3 if you
play rook captures on c3 then simply
Bishop captures on f4 this is what check
if you capture tells bishop then upon t1
becomes a queen
and if you move the King King do you
want then simply bushel capture some d2
attacks the rook and the rook has
nowhere to go
Plus the bishop is guarding the 1 square
4 tall to promote this pawn to a queen
on the other hand after rook captures on
c3 if you play Bishop captures on c3
then again there's nothing to do simply
Bishop captures and the bishop is
guarding d1 square there's it's all over
but okay
top played rook to d4 again a winning
move and here you can't play if you try
Bishop to e3 this doesn't work
simply rook captures on c3 rook captures
and now rook to d1 there is no way to
stop promotion
so after this rook to d4 attacking the
bishop botanique played Bishop 3-1 but
now comes Bishop Bishop to e5 check King
to g1 and now Bishop to f4 again tile
missed here the the the forcing rook
captures on c3 but he says you know it's
a winning position I don't want to make
any mistakes in calculations better to
go for but better to go safely so Bishop
to f4 attacking the rook and c1 and this
is why tile plated now if rook rook to
a1 getting the rock out of the way then
tal will finish with rook captures on c3
but when he saw that he can't go Roque 1
he played Knight captures and he - he
did get rid of the passed pawn but now
comes Luke captures on c1 Knight
captures on d4 and now rook captures
anyone with check bishop to f1 and now
bishop the e for not allowing botton
extinct to go anywhere and of course
rook captures on b7 is impossible
because of Bishop to d3 winning the game
so after Bishop e4 Knight to e2 by
botanique and now Bishop to e5 here Tull
is a pawn up he has the bishop pair and
bought unix pieces are completely tied
down this is winning however you play it
I mean you have played correctly
obviously so f4 Bishop to f6 and now
botanique captures on b7 pawn captures
we have roped rook moves as you can't
capture on a7 immediately because rook
captures night and then Bishop to d4
winning the rook on a 7 so rook to c7
now upon pawn captures and now you have
a rook captures as now the bishop on a2
is also attacked Bishop to c4 rook to e8
check a king f7 rook to h7 check King to
e6
rook moves and now d4 and now with
bottom Enix pieces completely tied down
there is no stopping the past D pawn but
when I tried a couple of more moves King
f2 no Bishop to h4 checked not allowing
the King to become active kingi to came
to d6 night to g3
here offering an
change but the rock endgame is
completely lost for botanique Bishop
captures Bishop captures pawn captures
King captures and now King to d5 rock to
a7 we have c3 rook to c7 King to d4 and
it was in this position that the game
was adjourned
so the game would be continued tomorrow
but tal knew that because he analyzed
this game thoroughly through throughout
the night and he saw that there is no
stopping the c3 pawn so later later when
the game was continued he simply showed
up and he didn't even care what bought
eunuchs move was gonna be as he knew
that bottoming who design the game on
the spot so he returned to the game and
bought eunuch did play rook to d7 but it
didn't matter as Botnick also resigned
in this position so yeah that's the game
really well definitely one of my
favourite games and I did try to cover
most of most of the ideas here but like
I said if you really want to see the
complexity of this game and all the
other games because style explains them
so brilliantly in his book do do get
this book as you know you're not gonna
be sorry so yeah once again I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
lemon Moreau and Georgie Oriole moto for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I will make both of them games from this
table - Nicole Chess Championship thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon so thank you all